arya is
far from fight ready i don't know if
arya is taking this as serious as he
should right now there's just something
that's just not clicking
i don't really know what it is
if someone's wrapping around your head
and neck what a proper guillotine right
we're gonna go two on one so both your
hands are gonna
trap the choking arm and pull it away
from the neck if you come up and you can
start pulling i'm gonna look up like
this
you don't have no power here
look up
good get your hips towards me
yeah see now i don't have power here now
you can spin
yeah hey there i'm arya and i have
started training once again in mixed
martial arts with the hopes the plan to
step back into the cage for a second
amateur fight over two years ago i
stepped into the cage after just four
months of training to fight my first
amateur bout i lost the fight in just
under a minute after i refused to tap
out to a guillotine choke and was
rendered unconscious
but for me it was always more than just
a win or a loss yes a win would have
been amazing but for me the victory was
stepping into that cage it was an
incredible personal journey and i
released a video about it on buzzfeed
and so many of you were so incredibly
supportive i still to this day receive
messages about that video and questions
about whether i would fight again
because i did at the end of the last
video say that i would fight again that
was over two years ago so much has
changed i mean let's not even start with
the state of the world even with myself
though so much has changed in my
personal life my professional life i
have a mustache now
i wanted to live up to the promise i
made at the end of the last video and so
i've begun training again with the hope
of fighting another amateur bout i've
brought back the exact same team i
trained with last time i have as my head
coach chris riley a legendary mma coach
and muay thai champion i'm also once
again working with daniel gutierrez who
runs defiant gym in burbank california
but this time around to make sure i
don't get caught in another fluke choke
that i somehow can't get out of i've
added a dedicated jiu jitsu coach in the
shape of scott epstein a third degree
black belt under the legendary eddie
bravo a tenth planet i don't know if it
was a fluke position i mean it could be
it's a guillotine he went for it it's
just not the best setup of our
guillotine it's kind of a weird shitty
one but because you had no knowledge of
oh i'm in trouble now you had no urgency
to get the [ __ ] out right jujitsu for
the layman it's kind of like wrestling
but instead of trying to pin the other
person
you're trying to make them say uncle tap
out give up
and there's a lot of joints that can be
manipulated into a position where it's
going to hurt really bad potentially
break a bone
or hyperextend the joint so the opponent
would have to give upset and then there
are chokes and the chokes if you don't
let go they go to sleep and if you don't
let go after they sleep they go into a
coma and if you don't go let go after
that they die mario
would not have gotten choked out in that
first fight if he had been training jiu
jitsu he would have smelled that out a
million miles away it wouldn't have gone
that far i don't know the outcome would
have been but it definitely would have
been choked out to that no shot
now there's a sense of urgency like wait
you ain't getting my neck homeboy get
the [ __ ] out of here
you know if if now it's gonna be i'm
getting your neck
[ __ ]
right
i'm gonna drop some illegal elbows on
you
you want me to get do you want me to get
you too no no no no it's not no
you missed the hook and the elbow
accidentally hit you
that's allowed accidentally yeah
30 seconds one two three two
again
hands up
proper punches with your body
chin down come on chin
that chin has to be corrected
immediately
good
good
good good hands
good good come on bring his hands back
up
isabelle
training has been uh
it's been something so i've been
training now for a little bit uh and
it's it's been tough you know getting
back into the swing of things after two
years off i certainly haven't been
training consistently uh since the last
fight especially you know when covid hit
you know like rolling around with other
people in a gym was probably the least
uh sanitary thing you could do in the
middle of a pandemic so you know i
wasn't going to the gym
uh for a long stretch of time so we just
basically went through some very basic
training and only a couple rounds just
simple faint jab cross hook i mean
you're pretty gassed
so
i think
you know we've got to really work on
your cardio and
once we do i think you'll start to see
some of your skills come back but
it's it's got to be done so we've just
now started easing back into training
and obviously with the time off arya has
slid back somewhat from where he was
when we actually stepped into the
octagon last time arya's gonna face a
lot of mental challenges this time
around i do think that you're dealing
with a level of awareness going into
this fight that you did not have going
into the first fight
and that in itself can be an obstacle to
overcome because when you haven't done
this yet you don't know how hard it is
so you just show up and do what you're
told and then all of a sudden the fight
day comes and
you walk out and you go out there and
you do it
but then the next time it happens
you're dealing with the knowledge of how
hard you had to work
how difficult it was to make that walk
into the cage and to face that guy and
the reality that you've gone back to
work and
gotten into a relationship and done the
things that people do in life and now
all of a sudden you gotta
step back into the gym and try to pick
up where you left off two years ago i
think that's a significant mental
obstacle that needs to be overcome i
don't know i feel
like a part of me that's struggling a
lot more i think mentally and then i
dealt with previously it's a different
type of struggle i feel like the doubts
i faced last time were more external
factors you know doubts from other
people you know if my body could even
handle the training but this time around
the the the struggle the doubts feel
different
it feels like they're more like
within me i can't really place a finger
on it but there's just something that's
just not
clicking i don't really know what it is
and the other thing that's
in the back of my mind is that i haven't
told
my mom or dad yet that i i might you
know be getting back in the cage
uh
which
i already know they're not gonna
they're not gonna be
uh ecstatic to hear
they you know um the last time i fought
my father didn't even know until it was
done because my mom didn't want to worry
my dad and when it was over i told my
mom don't worry
that's it you know
it's not gonna happen again and i
believed it in the moment i thought yeah
you know i did what i set out to do so
why do i get do i get back in there
so i don't know how i'm gonna break that
to them and so i think that's also kind
of
in the back of my mind
how are you
yeah the fight's over
how are you i'm good i'm good i i passed
out
no
uh yeah but i didn't tap
that's my dad
oh yeah
[Music]
okay
yeah
okay no more don't do any more right
we're finished
we're done i haven't been sleeping for a
whole week and everything so it's it's
like okay
yeah
now you can sleep it's it's all done
it's all done
it's over now
love you bye
[Music]
[Music]
at this point you're not doing enough
jiu jitsu and that is why you're here
because you got tapped you gotta choke
the [ __ ] out
make time to be here if it's important
to you
i can't help you if you're not here
you can't help you if you're not here
you should not take a [ __ ] fight if
you're not training for that fight we
don't want a false sense of security and
i'm not saying that you have this
but you don't want to be someone that
didn't really train for the fight but
you feel like you can win it because
that guy looks weak that guy kind of
sucks and did but that guy's busting his
ass and you you know you're editing till
three in the morning you're a positive
really sweet [ __ ] dude like you're a
kind
i don't see a shitty bone in your body
you know and that's a good thing
but you're gonna need a little
aggression
you gotta be like okay i have this thing
and i want to do well i want to win
it's not i want to test myself if you
just want to test yourself don't do it
don't do it
no more excuses no more late
and we're not showing up and sending me
a text message
i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't
i don't give a [ __ ] if you don't give a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] if you're here
and you care
i automatically care
that's on you
and if you don't feel right about it
don't [ __ ] do it
just got off the phone with my mom
and told her about my plans to
potentially fight in the cage again and
uh didn't record that call because uh
definitely didn't uh you know it wasn't
it went the way i expected you know my
my mother my mother wasn't too thrilled
obviously my mom was very concerned
to hear that i was going to potentially
put myself through that again and yeah i
mean it's definitely a it's definitely
something that gives me
pause
i think it's helped me kind of
understand a little bit more
about why things have felt off
for me with me last time around i was
laser focused there was nothing else on
my mind except for eating well training
well and doing everything i could to get
into the cage feeling as comfortable as
i could and i did that i i accomplished
that and
and
and i think that's what it is i think
i think i accomplished that
and so whatever that goal was that goal
isn't the same as whatever goal i have
now and i think what i'm struggling with
is finding
that
a goal a reason
whatever my reason would be for fighting
is different from other fighters right
because
i'm not looking to do this
professionally full time i guess what my
mind is trying to rationalize trying to
understand is like what what what is
what is the purpose what is my purpose
in doing this
other than pride other than
wanting to
to to make up for my loss last time
and if that is the only reason i could
come up with i'm struggling to
i'm struggling to
to see that as being enough
for
putting my
family putting the people who love me
who care about me through the stress of
seeing me in the cage again especially
have after having seen what happened to
me last time how much worse it could be
and furthermore not just for them but
also for myself you know like
i'm in a different place than i was
two years ago
i've been leaning into a lot more of the
filmmaking passion that i have i've done
documentaries for the unsolved network
i'm working on my own personal projects
you know things that i i wasn't really
carrying with me the last time around
and then there's other variables too
like i'm in a relationship now a great
relationship that i want to be able to
contribute to and not be like this
absent partner who's gone constantly
training this time around there's just
so many other things i feel
on the table
that i i feel responsible for and i
think that's why i'm struggling to
rationalize if just my pride alone if
fighting again for the sake of my pride
alone is worth all of that
all right so today let's get a couple
round of boxing sparring in it's been a
minute since you've been in the ring so
let's start easy just work jabs and
faints try to mostly just work with our
left hand the first round
and then we'll pick it up a little
hands up chin down
we've got to stay focused
[Applause]
[Music]
chin down hands up
come on
come on i'm not even halfway through
this second round what
i'm gonna go harder
one more
sparring sessions always act as a good
reality check and for the past few weeks
or maybe since then i've really began
training
uh this time around
it's i feel like it's all been one big
reality check
you know
so i don't know if aria is taking this
as serious as he should right now and
i mean i'm sure
he wants to do this but he's not
training the way he should he's not
doing what he's supposed to do in the
moment and i know there's also there's
work and there's projects and there's
whatever the [ __ ] going on in his life
that's holding him back but that's not
gonna
matter when he
if he
steps up and he gets in the cage
there you go
that was good i felt like there were
times where i was holding my own in the
sparring i was i was trying to compare
to the first time i ever sparred with
chris where i was just getting knocked
around like a ragdoll this time around i
was still getting knocked around like a
ragdoll but i feel like there were
flashes of moments where i thought okay
i can do this again right now it's time
to get going it's time to start treating
this like a fight camp and arya needs to
get his priorities in line
well there you go see
see you have the energy you just have to
believe in yourself
i realized though that a reality check
doesn't necessarily have to be a bad
thing because if anything this reality
check of all the sparring it reminded me
of what i can do
and i think i'm finally about to figure
out the reason why i'm stepping back
into the cage come on
you